[Music]
good to see you my man good to see you
it's been a while
yep it always is yeah you know coming
down here and seeing you and this was a
trip coming up here Wow
yes you were recording this on November
27th mm-hmm it's not gonna air until
January but you're here literally a week
after the Halsey fire yeah so you came
up in Malibu Canyon and Wow seeing not
only where the flames were but also the
the reddish pinkish fire retardant on
the hillside that is already impactful
and then you know melted fences and
things like that it's it's pretty
intense coming up here super intense the
firefighters and first responders did an
unbelievable job of ensuring that the
fire did not jump that road we live just
east of that about two miles as the crow
flies so we were very lucky and spared
and the wind was not blowing in our
direction but just on the east side of
Malibu Canyon Road it's just a it's a
lunar landscape yeah it's it's it's
pretty impactful coming up here and you
realize how how quickly that could have
moved or did move and you know how we're
not safe anywhere now I mean I live in
Marin County where you know how tight
the streets are and how overgrown it is
and man yeah it's intense we evacuated
Friday morning I woke up early the power
went out at like 6:00 a.m. and then the
cell service went out and that's freaky
you know and so I got in my car and
drove down the street to that corner
down the way and you can see fires on
the ridgeline and it was moving super
quick and I was like okay we're getting
out of here by the time we got down
downtown it had already reached the
beach it was moving it like the rate of
like they said they said like eight
football fields a minute or something
like that and just you know devastation
in its path and I've been going up on
some of the trails around here to just
kind of check out like what it looks
like and it's amazing like if you go
instead of turning right
my street if you've gone north to the
very end of lost virgin this road
there's a trailhead there and there's a
huge Nature Preserve you I mean you
could run an ultramarathon in there
there's tons of land that's protected
and it's completely just blocking it
yeah and you but I heard renewal happens
pretty quickly you see anything already
or we haven't had any rains down there
was one rain a tree after a couple hours
the other night I've heard that as well
I think we need a little bit more time
yeah and there's gonna be some more rain
coming this weekend so we'll see I mean
the next fear now is mudslides and all
of that of course for hey sync with us
yeah and I've got friends who have lost
their homes and plenty of friends
displaced a lot of friends still
displaced because power is not returned
and when you go to certain communities
further north along the coast
particularly like Point Dume and the
hillside above Zuma where Melville high
school is it's they got it really bad
there are there's so many houses are
gone crazy yeah crazy let me ask you
this when when you evacuated did you get
orders or did you guys sort of just
decide so what happened was a lot of
neighborhoods around here or the
surrounding neighborhoods were under
mandatory evacuation and because we had
no cell service or yeah or anything like
that like I didn't know I went down to
the firehouse down the hill here there's
a little neighborhood firehouse to just
find out you know what the status was
and you said that we weren't under
mandatory evacuation at that time there
was we left anyway but they invoked that
like I don't know the next morning or
something like that and what was
interesting was that I wanted to remind
them hey we have a swimming pool and we
actually have hookups for the hoses
mm-hmm they know that because they come
here and we have to clear our land every
year and you know we're friendly with
the the guys down there but in case they
forgot I just wanna you know we're gonna
leave the gate open so you guys can
access that water if you need it and I
said how's it looking and this is like
6:30 a.m. on Friday the the day of the
fire beginning and he said well it was
super windy too he's like look it's
picked Trancas as its line it's going
all the way to the beach there's no
doubt about it but you're gonna be fine
and he was pretty chill about it Wow and
he was exactly right
like these guys know oh yeah you know
they have so much experience at spotting
this and understanding how they have
these fires I mean they're like organic
you know Anthony study yeah yeah yeah so
my business partner Greg his company is
way out in Thousand Oaks and Thursday
because that's where the first fire
started in Thousand Oaks and like
Thursday midday he was with Jack Moscow
who is a kind of a legend around here
note you know local firefighter does a
big group like Century Ride every year
and Jack there was a fire way off in the
distance north of Thousand Oaks and Jack
apparently told Greg you guys got to get
out of here it's coming it's coming
directly here and it was so far away
Greg's like come on yeah waiting he's
like no I'm serious and he knew exactly
the path that that fire was gonna take
like that experience of fighting fires
for you know the breath of your career
or like they just have an ability to
it's amazing what those guys are all
amazing absolutely amazing and then when
you decided we're out of here
like how does that work what you chose
or not knowing I mean we didn't you know
we didn't pass it wasn't a panic yeah it
wasn't right there but it was serious
enough like hey you know the right thing
to do is to leave and we didn't bring I
mean I brought we brought our computers
and that was it I ended up coming back
on Saturday afternoon when it was under
mandatory evacuation and the cops had
the roads blocked off but I just showed
him my ID and they said you can go in
but you know you're at your risk and so
I came to the house and the only thing
we did was we took all the photographs
and photo albums and pack them into the
containers that we have and just locked
those because we couldn't bring all that
stuff downtown to where we were staying
but they would be relatively safer
versus being in the house should
something happen but it was super eerie
to be here on Saturday because there was
nobody here the winds had died down the
sky was orange you know and just ash was
falling everywhere and you could hear a
pin
and it was bizarre really weird Wow so
we got really lucky well I'm glad you
guys are okay and the rebuilding
hopefully in this community goes well
yeah well that's the thing that that has
been kind of profound about this
experience is seeing the community come
together you hear about this when you
know you talked to people that were in
Manhattan during 9/11 how the community
kind of congeals to support each other
and that's certainly been the case in
this community
yeah purpose right yeah but so many
people displaced and even people that
want to rebuild their homes there isn't
necessarily places for them to rent or
stay in the meantime because we now are
in a housing shortage so it's gonna be
interesting to see how that impacts the
community long term I would imagine
there's going to be some fracturing and
there's also you know that rates yeah
you know rental rates go up because it's
an opportunistic situation and that's
kind of like the downside of the whole
thing yeah so you guys have a lot ahead
of you still yeah
but anyway man sorry yeah well we're
gonna talk about new year new you how
endurance can can improve your life no
matter where you sit on the fitness
spectrum but before we kind of get into
that I haven't even sat with you in
person to talk to you about doing Oh
till oh this yeah yeah that's a little
you know I was with somebody who is
Swedish and I did my best so you know I
said I think I was like to the I was
like that's good right he's like now
laughed at me yeah I don't even attempt
it especially when I was in Sweden the
second time isn't it just now and I just
I came across as a good American right
Oh till oh right well they appreciate
the effort
oh yeah yeah so it was a little
different lately different like I've
said to a variety of people who have
asked me about it they keep it was like
swimming in a swimming pool uh-huh
compared to us like if if you would have
put lane lines between the islands it
would have been that smooth Wow and then
we actually had to put on sunscreen it
was that song hye-kyo and
just powerful Sun and not necessarily
warm but warm for Sweden in September
and then zero currents like remember we
had that one island that we went from
one island to the other and it was the
water was shooting on those rocks
between the two islands yeah and it
looked like a flume yeah like I had an
amusement park
mm-hmm and that wasn't him there this
year I was even telling my partner Frank
at the time I was like okay and over
this next hill we're gonna see this
really cool flume and it's really cool
current and it's probably gonna be
pretty cold in there huh nothing yeah
yeah we should say for if somebody's
listening his brand-new Otello is this
swim run race the swim run World
Championships that takes place in the
archipelago off the coast of Stockholm
every year at 75 kilometers and you swim
and run across how many Islands 26:26
Islands 52 transitions something like
that Chris and I did it together this
year prior and we had just epic weather
conditions
you know pouring rain sideways wind
Whitecaps crazy you know crazy surf the
whole thing and every aspect that you
can imagine was the opposite was the
hottest this year from no wind
- no swells - no chop - to warm
temperatures versus us but that the aid
stations people were wearing t-shirts
this year instead of full right foul
weather gear off of a sailboat haha and
hearty unbelievable yeah did you get hot
and the wetsuit that I did have to strip
it although we stripped a lot more than
we did just the top down a lot more
unzipping and caps off a lot more it got
pretty hot out there yeah and what did
you do differently like conditions aside
like from from the experience the first
experience which we did what did you
learn that you applied this time that
you think benefited you what benefited
me and my partner was definitely more
trail running definitely more sort of
jumping bouldering bouldering up in
Tahoe throwing more rock to rock tighter
turns tighter terrain well I definitely
changed expectations remember us with
our paddles yeah
our rite aid station times or cutoff
times I got rid of all what was it like
our original plan was we were gonna go
like nine hours yeah no I think we
wanted to go closer to 9:30 uh-huh
so I had those times on those same
paddles this year again and I was
looking at him before the race going all
right it was a lot easier year so we did
go an hour faster yeah but we walked
more than we did the year before huh
because my partner started getting up
calf cramps really bad he couldn't run
and also had some GI issues so you know
it was an hour faster but that's how
easy the conditions were this year and
the winners went over an hour and 15
minutes faster I mean they broke eight
hours by a lot right I mean and that
record I'll probably stay on for a while
believable
again you could fully swim and you could
see over a good 15 20 yards underwater
where your competitors were I mean it
was like I said a swimming pool and you
full stroke no problem right we're the
were there the jellyfish this year no
jellyfish really nothing I mean they
were just like everywhere you love her
and I think washed them up no it was
quite it was quite I mean to say easy is
sort of disrespectful and it's an
endurance of ours but compared to the
adventure we went on uh-huh it was
completely different like I thought they
put on an event in Croatia also Island
Highland hvar I think it's called and
going by the website of that it's like
we did it there right so it's not really
different feel tropical warmer smoother
easier in that respect because you're
not as fatigued on all the rocks they
weren't as wet we didn't slip as much
you know even though the spectators were
at such ease and not even in all of us
last year we did yeah we did it they
were they were in awe of us this was
sort of like that it's a beautiful they
were barbecuing
there was a barbecuing stops and
beer-drinking stops and that not for the
participants but respect a locals was
the pig swam flat - mm-hmm
yeah yeah it was again I wouldn't say
disappointing cuz that's the wrong word
for it but it was such the opposite
experience that what we had and how that
unfolded and us shaking our heads in
amazement mm-hmm so many times at the
top of those cliffs I mean that's gonna
be the lasting memory of a tillow for me
right always of course yeah I mean I
wouldn't change a thing no you know I
would have preferred when I was there
that it conditions but in retrospect I'm
perfectly happy that it was a challenge
that it was yeah and but still amazingly
organized those guys Michael mots are
still you know yeah do such a good job
and a variety of different people there
this year organized a little bit
differently we stayed we took buses to
it instead of a ferry
I took buses to the hotel and then in
the morning at like 4:30 we took a ferry
to the start versus being where we were
right so you wake up much earlier than
we did have to wake up much earlier but
imagine your night from the race night
when you did it with me and the shutters
were terribly I didn't sleep in this
whole place was shaken right it was like
an old hotel and these wooden shutters
would keep banging on the windows and
doors and you know that was all night
and the wind howling well this year a
there was no wind but we're also in a
super modern
nice hotel anything that could be
opposite happened opposite yeah were
there are other American teams there
yeah a lot of uh similar ones a couple
of similar ones the Texas team and Andy
who runs the all the Americas swim run
was writer again and yeah so a variety
of different teams the cars there Lars
was not there he was doing the one that
he was organizing with Lance and Simon
right right right he was busy for that
he was gonna do a race SOS it's called
uh on the East Coast Northeast but he
couldn't last minute so he was not there
unfortunately
so well it's cool to see swimrun kind of
getting a foothold in the u.s. scrub
what you know Lars is doing and that
organization there's more and more races
and then of course as you just mentioned
we saw lance and Simon Whitfield did
that race this year so it's cool and I
think it speaks to this this this need
or desire that a lot of people have to
extend their fitness journey and
experience beyond you know the local 5k
or the kind of races that we've grown
accustomed to to these more outdoors
nature based adventure challenges you
know yeah I mean I think it's hugs
deeply at the spirit and soul of a lot
of people I think Americans in general
since we're a very adventurous folk but
I think in all aspects of everybody
around the world of liking these outdoor
adventures and something that really
challenges them puts them on the far
edge of what they deem is possible a
little bit of fear a little bit of
respect for it and therefore that
motivating them to take on these
adventures and I think it taps into
something very deep within us like I was
saying to you earlier when you look at
an REI poster or a Patagonia catalog and
there's you just see the campsites and
the fire and these beautiful mountains
in the background
and there's something that tugs at you
that just wants to be outdoor that wants
to live in this adventurous way and I
think that's just part of who we are
from our evolution right being outdoors
and living on plains and being aerobic
ly active every day it's in our DNA and
then you know as I said last time on
this podcast I believe in that very
deeply Born to Run yeah it is Born to
Run but also that spirit of adventure
and however we take that on is part of
who we are yeah so we're seeing the
explosion of the ultrarunning community
I mean there's so many races now and
some of them just get crazier and
crazier and crazier like pushing the
envelope of
a human being is capable of doing but at
the same time you see challenges like
spartan race and the all the obstacle
course racing it's more accessible to
you know weekend warrior type people
challenges that people can wrap their
heads around that are adventure based
that get people out of their comfort
zone but are different and unique and
really bring the natural environment
into the authentic experience of you
know of the event itself yeah and I
think it's also important to recognize
there that the organizers besides
looking to make it sustainable
financially you want something where
it's not always this once a year event
right the hardest thing for an Ironman
or those type of distances you can't do
them more than right two or three times
a year and if these athletes which I
call them all athletes are in an urban
environment and to put something out
there that they can do multiple times a
year more than even once a month that's
that's a value because it keeps them
exercising it keeps them engaged in
being healthy and fit and self-care so
in the athletes that you coach are you
seeing more and more of them veering
towards these types of yeah more and
more adventures more and more curiosity
to what else they can do more and more
realizing a potential that's beyond the
Ironman or a 70.3 and not all of them
take on this adventure right away they
might be starting with a 10k and they're
doing it in a very methodical way right
and of course there's many of them that
I say we'll just let's just throw
something out there like we did with you
and just do it you know you learned so
much about yourself on that journey on
that path but again it has to be
something scary and that you respect
that keeps you engaged in the journey
right and not looking for an outcome not
looking for result not looking for
something to validate the ego of a
result but more this is what I truly
enjoy every single day or every other
day however we create
that plan but like I was saying to
others earlier as well is that that
daily check-in with yourself is so
important right that you spend some time
with yourself 45 minutes 30 minutes an
hour and a half a day over a week that
adds up to seven eight hours and where
you were truly within yourself your own
breathing your own heart rate feeling
your body move elevated heart rate
aerobic activity it awakens so much
within us that you are only positively
there's only a positive outcome from
that yeah more creative more patient
more energetic more I mean there's so
many studies and so much science has
already verified this but I think it
also touches into something deeper that
we want to be able to hear what our body
is telling us it's just there's so much
static every day in our lives that it's
hard to hear it and getting a chance to
work out no matter what environment is I
mean of course there's treadmills and
trainers - closing your eyes on a
trainer and having the ride time goes by
very slow as we know but again your
ability to practice that every day makes
five minutes go to ten minutes go to 20
minutes go to 60 minutes real quickly
and there's a lot of reflection and time
in there where you can sort of reset the
operating system once a day yeah time
becomes very malleable in endurance
training like I just know that at the
beginning of a season a to our bike ride
just feels like forever and then by the
end of the season that eight our bike
ride feels like shorter than the
two-hour it's it's weird your
relationship with time it's like like oh
I've been going six hours I only have
two hours more that's like a movie or
all you know like nope down no big deal
I notice it most swimming yeah open
water swimming at the beginning of the
season you know you're swimming for ten
minutes and it feels like oh that must
be 30 minutes but then the more you do
it the more you actually get in tune
with the true timing of your body yeah
and I think the same thing happens
running inside
clean as well well to that point of you
know being born to to move our bodies in
a certain way I mean you know what I
always feel and say is that I don't I
don't feel like I'm myself unless I'm
doing these things you know then I feel
whole I feel complete I feel like I'm
the best version of Who I am when I
returned from a workout and you feel
invigorated and you feel present and
focused and capable all of those things
I think it does run very very deep into
our DNA and you know who who we are as
human beings and it were able to give so
much more if we take care of ourselves
on a daily basis and it sounds selfish
in some ways oh my workout or my
exercise but your energy your patience
your vitality towards work towards
family towards community all that
changes when you are yourself have
gotten in your time every day yeah so
you've been an athlete your entire life
yeah since you were a young boy
you went from Olympic swimmer right into
professional triathlete right into you
know high ranking amateur endurance
athlete coach all of this sort of thing
you never have you ever taken a break I
have what is the longest break you've
ever taken um probably 30 years yeah 6 6
8 weeks most about torturous for you um
yes it was but on the other hand I mean
it's hard to look back at it now it was
more torturous then but now I reflect
back and go oh it was the greatest thing
that could have happened at the time
because you know I needed relationships
that needed mending or something to be
done at the end the house where I was
available for my children more it just
resets again and you you realize what
you need to focus your priorities on
yeah you must have people that look at
you strangely though and think you're
just some kind of alien being because
you've got you're always out there well
they talked about that lately this
Fitness age versus your true age there
was just an article the other day just
reading about that the other day too and
it talks about how many years you've
been training to sort of make it your
fitness age and in some cases it makes
you
older cuz it'll wear and tear on your
body and the stress and then they also
have this other theory on Fitness age
making you younger because you know
you're healthier and so forth so I'm not
sure yeah category I truly fall into
please yeah I have been doing this at a
high level all my life but the the part
there that I try to tell people as much
as I can is because I've done it through
all phases of my life there's a way I
can help you navigate how to do this and
whether it's a 10k 5k 100 mile run
Ironman Ultraman you know whatever the
adventure is there's a way to navigate
and through our visualize you're still
growing in your career there's still
some career learning or education you
want to take on there's family there's
community there's church there's Little
League there's all those things right
but you can still satisfy that personal
interest of endurance athletics and that
is we we set the expectations a little
bit like you're not gonna win an Ironman
right I mean you might but again we will
know once we're digging our heels into
the training and then secondly it's the
timeline if we have if in three years we
want to do an Ironman that's different
than if we want to do one in three
months of course the trainings gonna be
different and so my value that I try to
give to the athletes as much as I can is
help them navigate their day their life
their priorities their career in order
to still do this right so people are
going to be listening to this and in a
state of engagement with their New
Year's resolutions but also three weeks
into the new year that's when people
start to already fall off their big
ambitious you know goals that they've
set for themselves at the end of
December so for people that are in North
America or in the northern hemisphere I
should say we're in the we're in the you
know we're in the thick of winter this
is a this is a challenging time to stay
engaged and active with your fitness so
what is the counsel that you give the
athletes that you work with about this
period of time this
well usually since is coming out after
the holidays usually I give them focus
on post holidays right where it's a
let's kick out of the holidays in some
way we were somewhat connected to
fitness we're not an ideal fitness but
were somewhat connected to it but when
we're talking January that's when we
start approaching we're in 2019 we're in
the new year and hopefully we have found
a goal of something that excites you
where you close your eyes at night and
it motivates you you feel good excited
you can envision yourself doing it and
being alive and having fun and smiling
and really being passionate about it and
then it's question of how are we
building that long-term roadmap towards
that it doesn't need mean II mean that
we have to attack this this weekend with
long workouts
it's about getting consistent about
doing a little bit something every day
and how are we on the path towards
achieving that outcome and we have to
enjoy it I mean sure sitting in a
basement on a treadmill is not that much
fun in January right or in February or
March in many places but if it's
something where you still can close your
eyes and see value in doing it because
you're excited about the outcome and
therefore can enjoy this journey bedroom
you know training time like I was saying
earlier not only is it self-care time
but a lot of people look forward to it
to catch up on books on tape or audible
or something like that to listen to
their podcasts to reflect on their day
to think about what their intentions for
the day it's a very unique time that you
have to yourself every day and you can
basically take all your New Year's
resolutions and get them done in that 45
to 90 minutes a day right or 30 minutes
a day reflection intentions future goals
health what am I gonna cook for dinner
how am I gonna have breakfast tomorrow
what am I going to do this weekend how
am I gonna plan my kids all that can be
done when we spend some multitasking but
that's part of it like you know from
when you go out trail running after
about 20-30 minutes your mind starts
freeing up and things start the portal
opens right not only to our unconscious
self and some bigger thoughts and some
real meaningful thoughts but also some
real clear things about you that you
which may be tossing around ideas with
or trying to figure out it all just
starts becoming a lot more clear yeah
you get out of your own way yeah I think
when you're intently focusing on solving
a problem solving a problem solving a
problem and you're banging your head
against the wall and you can't see your
way through you've got a you've got to
clear your head you know and for me and
I know for you running or a bike ride
like an in like a low-intensity
endurance effort is a great way of like
just anchoring you in the present to
allow your unconscious mind to take hold
and I just find that I returned from
those sessions with a certain clarity
that I can't get otherwise and then the
solution appears so it's almost like
this bizarre equation that doesn't make
logical sense where I'm more productive
I'm more focused when I'm actively
engaged in my training because I can
problem-solve at a higher level yep you
go out for a run and come back and your
answers you're somehow there right the
other thing you learn to trust that oh
yeah absolutely yeah and and some of
your best creative ideas come from that
and problem-solving the biggest thing
with that though is that it's
remembering your ID snomint like write
it down or make like a voice memo or
chef and even though it sounds funny I
listen yourself panting I didn't think I
was that out of breath yeah but the
other thing with January and February
too for us in northern hemisphere
athletes is be creative in how we get
the heart rate up right I always say to
my athletes and I've said this too on
the podcast here the heart doesn't know
what it's doing it could be doing
jumping jacks
skate skiing snowshoeing riding its bike
running whatever it is and if you're
getting your heart rate up a little bit
every day or every other day which
depends on what we're getting ready for
use the environment and the terrain to
your advantage to have fun with it right
there's so many different adventures
things we can do in the winter from
trail running and
in rainy days and the gears awesome
these days - snowshoeing and skate
skiing and downhill skiing and hiking I
mean use the season and the environment
to help you stay connected motivated -
then when the weather does turn and you
can truly do the activity that you're
getting the event ready for then you'll
be plenty fit to quickly shift the body
around yeah I had Kilian Jornet here
recently and he's like the ultimate
example of that I mean that guy just
basically skis in the winter he's not
running he's not running year-round like
I asked him why are you able to maintain
your like primacy like in a world of
ultra runners where you see people have
one or two great seasons and then be
unable to match that ever again he's
consistently at the top and I was like
what do you attribute that to and he's
like because I do a million different
things yeah he keeps it interesting and
he stays engaged with his fitness but it
changes based on the season and the
terrain that he's in and he's not
running year-round and their diet
changes based off the season as well
right as well as from a longevity
standpoint allowing yourself not to take
everything so single-mindedly focused
also helps you along that journey so
maybe and I don't know him it's because
he can turn that off for a couple months
a year and not worry about the outcome
and the result is much and just listen
to his body I think that is a huge
benefit well when you do turn the switch
on that it's there with all its energy
and all its focus when needed yeah it
requires a certain level of confidence I
mean I think most people get neurotic
about it and like well if I'm not doing
that but I'm falling behind and falling
behind yeah well there is no falling
behind as it masters athlete Yeah right
I mean we only have our own path and
that's why you know comparing to others
Rob's the joy of it right if you were
stuck always looking at what we want to
achieve or a past self of what we have
achieved
you're never gonna enjoy it yes
January's gonna end and your
to quit that gym membership yeah you
learned that I mean both having had
competitive swimming careers you learn
that quickly in the pool like I just
don't even worry about what the pay
scale says cuz she's so hard to not
measure yourself against you know those
years and years and years where you
could hit those certain interval no
problem and especially now during the
holidays all the kids come home from
college and stuff like 12 year old and
quickly you get moved down four lanes
man right yeah what do you think is the
biggest mistake that most a masters or
amateur athletes make around this time
of year well it's the thinking that you
have to keep this perfect string of
workouts going right if you get 80% of
your week done if you get three four
days together strung together done well
and you miss a day that's fine right
we're all not gonna be a hundred percent
on any of this I'm never 100% on any of
this let alone most of my athletes life
gets in the way right we all went pro in
something other than this master sports
and so not judging ourselves not
worrying too much about missing a day
because the next day you're gonna come
back more motivated more focused as well
as fresher and more recovered and feel
better doing it so don't look for
perfection look for steady gradual
progress mm-hmm consistency
yeah because especially as masters
athletes as I like to call us especially
as swimmers we remember how we used to
be right and we have this image when we
take on an event whether it's an Ironman
whether it's a swimming race whether
it's a running race how we used to be
and how when we had a lot of time and no
kids and not a career that demands a lot
of us and so forth oh that's what it
felt like that's how I how I felt and
that's how the rhythm of the training
went well that was 20 years ago right
like you forget and you have to adjust
those expectations and that's why I
always say we can take on any endurance
event we just have to adjust the
expectations however you want to achieve
it we can achieve it but let's work
around what X
vacations are for the endurance athlete
out there how important is the strength
work like time in the gym this time year
well besides that I will always say it's
individual to the person strength work
is quite important the beauty of
strength work that fits really well in
with the seasons of endurance training
and endurance athletics is that this is
a great time of year when the rain is
here the snow is here the cold
temperatures to work on those things
it's again taking advantage of the
environment we're in spending the next
12 weeks 16 weeks on strength and
mobility especially mobility more than
strength and mobility ties in stability
work what I call chassis integrity you
know core stability things like that um
so that then come the spring we can put
a bigger load on the body when it's time
but yeah I'm a big believer in strength
work not for everybody because what's
our the best use of our limited time
right so some people we do just need to
run okay we just need to get them moving
and running or walking in some cases
others were better off spending that
strength time if there are no more on
temperate climate on the bike right we
can do to hill repeats on the bike at a
low kids and really work those leg
muscles very similar to squats but
you're doing a very sports specific do
you have a specific mobility / strength
/ core workout that you recommend people
yeah no I sort of fudge them all
together from a variety of different
people that I've worked with things that
I've liked plans that I've applied and
see how they work that's the that's the
fun part right for me even now at this
time of year I'm going through some
different strength work and versions of
strength work that I will then in two
three weeks and on to my athletes like
some of that cattle ball stuff yeah yeah
a ttle ball a lot Ocala bail I did it
again
I had a I got like crucified cuz I had
Mike Mahler in here he's like an expert
in kettlebells and I was caught I was
calling him kettle balls
yes kettlebells medicine balls dumbbells
I like all that because again we want to
manage the load and kettlebells because
they're so versatile allow you to do a
lot of out work and guess what for 30
bucks on Amazon for 50 bucks on Amazon
you can get a pretty good set and do
most of this stuff in the comfort of
your home 30 minutes and you are getting
huge benefits from that strike four hmm
single leg lunges and squats and
explosive jumps and so forth from from a
leg standpoint core work and you know
all kinds of crossover work that you can
do with kettlebells that works really
really well yeah how many of your
athletes are working on self-styled
challenges that they just came up with
themselves curated as I call them
curated what you call I call them you
can curate your own you know you gotta
go with the buzzword these days um as
the kids call it merch I learned just
the other day you can kids watch like
you're getting swag you're getting birch
them them curate their own adventures I
would say about 40% of them it's gone
now it's gone way up um they've done a
variety of a higher man's they've done a
few organized longer events and now
they're more looking for adventures that
they sort of can put together not in
their backyard but within two three four
or five hours of driving right and again
a lot in California or even here in
North America there's adventures to be
found anywhere so yeah it's it's
happening a lot more just people
exploring even their area and their
neighborhoods and their their parks
within two three four hours right we
have your cemani here we have John Muir
Trail we have the Pacific Northwest we
have desert we have mountains I mean
there's so much to be done there I keep
looking at events around the world and
then I realize we've got some epic stuff
just around here what's one of the
cooler either sanctioned races or
curated experiences that you've come
across the
new and different um well that's a no
you caught me unprepared for an answer
um there's a there's a variety of them
well the one that I was telling you
about earlier is really cool that um
that Riki Gates is doing I think that's
his name
in San Fran in every city street in San
Francisco on consecutive days and he's a
Salomon runner so he's a very very good
ultra trail runner but yeah he's running
every single Street in San Francisco and
I think it's like close to 400 miles
well I'm sixty-five thousand feet of
elevation gain or uh elevation change
baby just in the city of suggests missus
idiot reversing every Street every speck
trying not to overlap exactly otherwise
he's just out there for more and more
money just doing it every day waking up
and yeah yep and he did it through the
smoke just now with all the fires from
the Paradise the the campfire and so
those are things that are really cool I
mean just think of that doing that in
your own hometown or just getting to
know your own area that well where you
see the diversity the culture of your
city of your town corners that you never
realized existed right that's that's
what I love about outdoor adventures
that truly fits that right where you
find something well I can't afford a
$700 $800 Ironman right escaped from
Alcatraz this year is 715 huh yeah
really you were just showing me a
picture from a long time yeah I'm doing
it it must have been 150 then oh wow
it's most it's 750 dollars and it's
lottery base to get in so so a lot of
people can't afford all that right um
the gear the Garmin watches all that you
put all that together it becomes too
much it becomes overwhelming in a lot of
ways and so there it's like let's figure
something out together like let where do
you live what can we do to make
something exciting cool unique
adventurous for you and then train for
it and get excited about it and connect
with your community with it and or raise
funds for charity or something like that
where you're directly impacting your
hometown your community and showing
others even just your friends even just
two or three people yeah I'm driving two
hours to go this beautiful State Park
because it's worth discovering yeah I
like that just making it accessible but
also exciting and different and new
allowing people to take ownership of
their community and unique way
absolutely there's an endurance
adventure awaiting anywhere right I mean
sure we have people swimming around
Great Britain right yeah but we also
have people swimming across huge lakes
or you know there's adventures happening
all around us all the time and that's
the beauty of social media but it's also
the beauty of people becoming more and
more curious of what their potential is
and they find out that the new normal
puts the potential even further out
there yeah I think also it's not about
the longest that you can go or the
craziest or you know it's it's about
being the best version of who you are
within the confines of whatever that
challenge is I mean a four mile a 5k can
be as hard as a hundred mile er if you
put the time into it and I'm always
encouraging people to just let go a
little bit of like oh it's got to be the
craziest thing everyone's ever heard of
yeah we've created really high
expectations in our community of what
makes it cool but it doesn't need to be
like that right you getting fit and
healthy and self-care and focusing
inwards and outwards a little bit every
day and understanding your environment
around you better that's all positive
and trust me the outcomes even if you do
that local 10k even if you do that local
half trail marathon are always positive
I've never heard anybody say man I
shouldn't have done that that was a
waste of my time exactly yeah I mean the
devastation alone like they cancelled
the North Face races two weeks ago
because of the fires and the smoke right
we had seven eight hundred and four
thousand people because there's all
kinds of distances in Marin County
Grambling to find something to get out
there and do right because they were fit
they were ready and you know they worked
hard to get to this point and so again
off they went
I know people speaking of your question
before they just created their own race
they ran it a week later it all got
together you know the beauty of social
media this past weekend there were 3 30
40 50 people in groups running the
course right we don't need it for a
finish line or put our results on a
website or fit we want to do it
it was beautiful weather this past
weekend right we just waited a week
until the smoke clear they still
fulfilled their their intention right
because goals become really black and
white I must finish like this but their
intention was to do this this event I
had to finish it to be out in nature in
the woods and Marin Headlands it's
gorgeous and they fulfilled their
intention it's very important to have
that closure yeah you've uh you've
evolved a lot you're like so much more
open and broad-minded than when we first
met
yeah so I'm curious and it's great its
beauty male about this the other day
from an athlete that I answered his
question on my podcast and he's like
it's so weird to hear an Olympic swimmer
an intense elite athlete talk about all
this you know deep emotional psychic
hair higher consciousness best version
of ourselves right and yeah so focus a
German super hardcore
Olympian hard-ass and be all that yeah
yeah it's what is that what do you
attribute that to I think I had well I
know a few things of course being
knocked silly on my you know bottom
through divorce and resetting priorities
right we all go to life shifting events
and sometimes they have a big impact on
us right and to this day I can attribute
it to it was the first time in my life
not sort of the world flowing
the path that I wanted to somebody else
took that path away from me not in a
negative way not saying anybody's fault
it was just because I was no longer in
control and every set my recalibrated my
entire world and being more appreciative
and understanding sort of more that
there's more to the world than just me
yeah and to put it bluntly right like
quite honestly I grew up as an athlete
everything always went my way so I was
pretty self said write and throw in
there that that German heritage the
preciseness yeah the joke was always
people would say to me I mean as years
and years ago like hey I'm thinking of
hiring Chris and I'm like all right well
you know don't hire them if you if you
want a pat on the back or somebody's
gonna like be a cheerleader because he's
not that guy you know he's he'll write
the plan for you the plan will be
amazing he will hold you accountable
yeah but if you need emotional support
like no you got exactly yeah and so um
and a lot of that also became aware to
me running ultra runs and trails I mean
that really holiday that comes with all
the humility and that there is no time
right and that you just get lost in the
woods and I had a lot of time out there
was like this is my church you know I
run out here in this beautiful nature
created by some higher power it is
absolutely gorgeous I feel so connected
to life the environment nature myself
everything all beings and so forth love
the whole thing and realizing there is
no weather I get first fifth 25th nobody
can take away the experience I'm having
right now in nature do feeling this fit
feeling this alive and that's what I
tell a lot of my athletes to this day
don't let anybody rob you of your joy
and journey in nature training and doing
this every day
that's self-care that's very protected
time every day you deserve that not only
will others benefit from it but also
that's your precious precious time and
don't let anything rob you of that
opportunity every day to go inside
yourself and exhale
yeah that's the experience that I want
everybody to have exactly you know it's
it's it's a sense of feeling connected
to yourself of feeling alive of being
connected to nature and your environment
in in a way that I don't know any other
way to achieve that other than to be
actively engaged with my body in that
way I mean meditation a variety of other
ways to alter your mind whether it's you
know ayahuasca or immersion tanks
there's so many ways these days but one
of the ways for me is training out in
nature immersing myself truly in nature
or just daily you know not always am i
running in the woods and it's this
idyllic scene just me I'm gonna
treadmill every now and then too but at
least closing my eyes and resetting
myself and saying listening to my body
hearing that heart rate and that heavy
breathing and just going okay there we
go I'm back to the true setting my
evolutionary self yeah even just for 30
seconds a day because it takes a while
to reset that every day right to finally
have the mind clear and get to a point
where it's like all right there we go
and everybody I know everybody has
experienced some sort of reset before
and where they whether you take a long
shower and you come out invigorated or
it's exercise or it's meditation or it's
just a great night's sleep or sitting
somewhere on a rock overlooking
something or the beach there's so many
ways every day that we have an
opportunity to sort of take a deep
breath reset and find ourselves and say
alright well I got this that like you
said we can connect that to as many
people as possible that's that's it
mm-hmm so with this evolution that
you've been on how has that impacted
your you're like downstream how you
interact with and coach your athletes
like what has changed in how you create
programs and communicate with your
athletes versus perhaps what you might
have done five or ten years ago
five or ten years ago is more
outcome-based
I can help you achieve X qualifier or
this time or this result and now it's
more about the process the journey I
want to get you out there doing it I
want to help you achieve not only what
you're curious about but also help you
navigate through it all so that you can
stay in some sort of balance right we
have family we have work we have our own
self care if we can take those three and
somewhat keep those all those balls
juggled in the air at the same time then
we're really getting to that version of
ourselves that we're really happy with
maybe not the best version of ourselves
but a pretty good outcome of that and
there's gonna be times where of course
work and professional life takes a
bigger balance bigger part share of the
balance right but doesn't mean we stop
training it doesn't mean we stop
exercising it just means we have less
hours available or we pick and choose
our windows when we train a lot more
strategically or there's times where
family and career take on a bigger role
and so you know navigating through that
that's what I work I want to work with
my athletes most on right and they're
open to that growth and they're open to
that exploration in the meantime a lot
of my newer athletes who are who say you
know what I want to figure this out and
I want to work with you in order to
figure it do you ever come across like a
clone of a younger version of you who's
like I don't hear about that
I just I'm here to qualify for Kona just
give me the full head I do yeah I do
come across this but the beauty is there
they actually sort of get it too they
might not like fully embrace it but they
get that this is about balancing and
longevity if great you make it to Kona
this year but if you do this wrong I
cannot already tell them you know I've
been where you've been in your late
twenties early thirties Kona's
everything and you're gonna be done in
two years because you can't keep burning
that match the way you are right right
whereas if you care about doing this for
many years and really want to get to the
of Kona which you're not gonna do in
your first year or your second year we
have to do this in balance early on and
then you've got a couple of years to
really hit your potential there and that
they do get and I would have even him
back in my day understood that somewhat
mm-hmm if somebody told me that in in
working with the group of athletes that
you've worked with what is the
consistent challenge that kind of comes
up across the board or complaint or or
barrier that people are confronted with
that you have to help them through yeah
this is an easy one the hardest part of
being a coach is communication
the athletes willingness to communicate
with me of all things
uh-huh because the more I'm armed with
their communication the better of a plan
we can write together right because it
is we write it together you give me your
limiters you give me your challenges
your schedules your stresses and I can
work a plan around that and then you say
well this doesn't work on I'll have a
soccer game on Saturday and my daughter
does this on Sunday I'm like all right
well let's get up at 5:00 and get those
two hours done there and then in the
afternoon stresses off your table your
unstressed about joining the soccer game
or going through the gymnastics meet or
doing this because we got it done but
you're gonna have to go to bed you know
before 1:00 a.m. on Saturday so there's
a give-and-take so managing that and
then the other aspect of communication
of how they're feeling what they're
observing like being vulnerable to this
guy yeah on the other end right and we
know it from being coached all our lives
all right we were coached as young kids
a lot of people have been coached before
and it's one of my questions on when I
ask athletes have you been coached
before because knowing how to be coached
to open yourself up to allow yourself to
be coached is very very different than
just receiving a plan right we had the
luck and the the joy actually of coaches
who were on deck and can see us every
day
food her impatience our crankiness our
fatigue right our bodyweight all that
when it's though all those things are
indicators and this guy might be a going
a bit over the edge or he might need a
recovery week or well they didn't have
recovery such thing as that but you
learn to communicate feel exactly and
you're so in touch with your body that
you have you develop this language for
expressing where you're at and I think
that's new and different for people that
are coming into it later exactly and I
see that in the logs right like the way
that people communicate and they're like
well I hit these power numbers but I'd
miss this it's like yeah I already see
that from the data I don't know like you
know how it felt what did you do versus
of how did it feel versus last week this
is your heart rates are a little off
what's going on here are the other
stresses in your life did you have
dinner last night you should have been
able to crush these intervals why did
you feel like that right oh yeah I skip
dinner I was where I worked late and
came home family time and next thing I
know I had maybe only a bar right well
of course now we're getting into now it
all makes sense now I can actually coach
that athlete and let them know don't be
so hard on yourself on how that workout
went look it's very clear here on why it
didn't work that way right and then
their confidence is boosted of course
because now it all makes sense if they
didn't tell me that in four weeks from
now they're completely completely upset
about their training mm-hmm right
because they don't understand why it's
going so bad but we haven't broken into
everything that they can fix very easily
to be successful with this yeah and I
think for people that are listening to
this who don't have the benefit of
working with someone like yourself you
can develop this on your own whether
your journaling it in pen and paper or
uploading your workout data to one of
these portals like training Peaks you
can start to write out on a daily basis
you know connect with yourself how did
you feel how did you eat how did you
sleep and you start to get a roadmap or
a picture of where you're at that can
help you you know avoid mistakes as they
come up as
more you learn about yourself and how
you function and it's another great way
of how athletics bleeds into the rest of
our days if you learn how to journal
your athletic self right your daily
workouts and how you felt you know easy
it is the journal about because you have
practice with it five minutes of every
day how did it feel what did I observe
how do I recover any other inputs how do
I feel versus last week and quickly you
just get very good at observing during
the workout what you're gonna note later
on in the log and the same thing works
with you know journals in general how
much value do you put into all of these
new sort of biomarker devices like the
aura ring and heart rate variability I
mean we can track so much more than we
could even a couple years ago like does
that do all those additional inputs play
into how you coach athletes or no I
still trust their gut the most and what
they observe the best athletes that I
have and not because of results but
because we work together very well are
the ones that can truly figure out they
know when they're getting sick before
they're gonna get sick right I got it at
an email this morning I feel a little
off I think I might be getting sick what
should i do tomorrow should I take off
or should I go on feel my said well
knowing you and how long you've been at
this with me you feeling it already is a
good sign
I trust that so let's back off the
intensity tomorrow go by feel lonely
maybe not take off and if it's still
tracking worse well know you're gonna
get sick right but again being in tune
with your body as part of that whole
self-care right not only from a a growth
perspective of our own personality soul
and higher self but also being in tune
everyday with hearing what your body is
telling you is important right because
you know then if you're getting sick you
know of something's off they say I was
just reading the other day oh um sapiens
that marami book fascinating stuff those
books I'm on the podcast oh okay and the
he was saying that how you know when you
get really sick like a cancer type of
sickness it needs to travel through the
mind before you feel it and before you
go to the doctor right but again our
practice and I thought made me think of
it our practice of daily checking into
our bot with our body and our breathing
and how we're feeling and we have enough
data of doing it every day for many
years on an end um that you'll track
that stuff even earlier
well you become like an intuitive
superhero you know we've talked about
this before but a perfect example of
that is you know when we were kids and
we were swimming in high school or
college you know I could tell you with
absolute precision
every time my hand hit the wall what
that 100 reapeat was was it a 58 was it
a 50 - was it a 101 like you would know
because you're so connected yeah and
that just comes with a lot of reps and a
lot of experience but the more that you
invest you are not just physical energy
but your mental energy in paying
attention to those things and the
journaling certainly helps you you
develop that capacity yeah that does
spill over in the other areas over
person I like how you said that
intuitively because again being in tune
with our body in harmony there's so many
other benefits that stream from that
right and knowing that we want to get in
tune once a day makes a huge difference
down the road it's an investment in
ourselves but once you're there it's I
mean like we said earlier six to seven
to eight hours a week of practicing that
that's 45 minutes of training a day
right like just think if you're doing
you know something longer and you're
doing 10 12 16 20 hours a week if you
use the majority of that time to resync
with yourself and be in harmony you will
know so much more about yourself in
order to again put forth this healthier
smarter version of yourself right all
right well we got to close this episode
of coaches corner down but like I want
you to just imagine it's late January
it's dark it's cold it's way
you set that goal at the end of December
but your enthusiasm is starting to wane
what are the key most important things
that people can kind of latch on to hang
their hat on to carry them into the
spring months well you've heard this
from me many times before but there's a
little physician more tricks to it in
the mean time and that is just doing
something a little something every day
right consistency and don't beat
yourself up if it's only thirty minutes
that's plenty to get the heart rate
going but let's say you're on a
treadmill right or on a trainer bike
trainer where you put your bike on on a
resistance trainer like things that I
say to my athletes is you know let's say
you have the TV on every time there's a
commercial that's when you run harder
you run it to two miles an hour faster
and then when your show comes back on
back to easy right use everything as in
your environment to your advantage to
keep you motivated to keep it fun
save that TV show that you want to watch
on Netflix for being on the trainer or
save that song or that music or that
podcast or your podcast for when you're
on the treadmill right and you're stuck
in the dark times or in a gym with a
billion people and you don't really want
to interact right now you just want to
exhale you've had a long day
save that for them to listen to that
music or that new CD or CD CD yeah how
old are you like what would or a podcast
right and so again use those things to
your advantage to get you out there
every day the other thing that I use and
my athletes know this is I put out an
index card when I go through hard times
every night and I put it right by my
coffee in the morning so that that index
card has my workouts for the day on it
and just seeing that index card there
with a few intentions it's not big you
know so it's small little index cards
lying there and seeing it first thing in
the morning when I'm tired and sleepy
and walk and turn on the water you know
already
okay well that I can do right it's just
that index card I have to put that in a
box at the end of the day at some point
today I want to get
that done right I like that another
little trick that I use is to prepare
for the following days work out the
evening before by doing simple things
like okay it's a run so I'll pull out
the shorts and the socks and like kind
of get everything ready and organized to
make it as easy as possible to begin
that work out the next day and I think
just the simple act of organizing that
creates an emotional investment that
makes it harder for you the next day to
not do it or have it with you like you
have any out karlik or at times but I
also like to do that you know that
podcasts are really intriguing right
because you see what the topics are and
you load them the night before and you
look forward you create your playlist
look forward
oh I'm curious as to what this guy has
to say or what she is contributing I
like this one this one's only 30 minutes
though so I got to make sure I have and
I know it's gonna follow that so you
have to stop and yeah well but we also
know once that initial momentum happens
you're out the door you're going right I
mean not that but like I I don't want to
have to stop my workout to hit play in
the house laying like I want it all
killed she'll it'll just flow okay yeah
yeah get in a little something every day
don't try to string together too many
days perfectly in a row just look at
yourself big picture a lot of times I
also say where do you want to be on
January 31st nothing crazy
not something for June yet how do I want
to feel in January 31st how do I want to
feel February 28th or whatever it'll be
this year so give yourself short-term
outcomes that you say okay that I can
achieve I just need to be a little bit
better at the end of January then I was
at the end of December right and then
you're making progress so that you can
set the marker for next month out there
but this is what I want to achieve right
you can chart it you can there's a lot
of ways to keep you excited about the
next week but if you have short term
goals that you feel good about achieving
it'll just create momentum once again
always good advice my friend yeah been
at this for a long time yeah it's not a
it's not rocket science it's is
and sense stuff yeah but it's important
to remind ourselves that that there are
there are ways of approaching these
things to make it easier versus harder
and reward yourself right like a lot of
times I hear I talk about nature take a
week off go hiking in the snow do
something completely different
right like use your fitness early on to
do something you know what a month ago I
wouldn't have been able to do this but
now I feel pretty good about doing it
right cool all right man well until the
next Coach's Corner yeah
until then thank you for your wisdom my
friend as always in your council and for
everything that you've you've done for
me if without you I would not be sitting
here doing this so you you've done a lot
for all of that and for people that are
new to Chris he's pretty easy to find on
the internet at AI MP coaching comm at
AI MP coach on Twitter you know and the
week the weekly word podcast yeah how's
that going it's going well you know I
dive deep into the head yeah people I
keep thinking people are gonna get tired
of hearing just me talk yeah I don't
know how you do that but they're they're
good that's a it's a steady stream of
listeners and now I have a newsletter a
weekly word newsletter that has my
favorite workouts in its and nutrition
tips some cool races that's good so you
just sign up on your website for that
and then that works great because people
get a short tidbit it's only once a
month I don't I don't have the time
weekly but you know that's exactly what
you were asking before a cool new race
that came across or you know a great
adventure that one of my athletes just
completed won one of them right now is
in Antarctica really he's finishing the
4 deserts and the final desert right now
he's in he's since Sunday he's been a
night arctica Wow I mean that's not a
super cool that's why he chose yeah what
am i doing yeah cool man all right man
till next time
yeah peace thanks Chris plants
[Music]
you
[Music]